from method acting Madness to weird food
choices to the place Johnny Galecki
stuck all of his used chewing gum these
actors had some seriously gross onset
habits when Robert Pattinson landed the
role of Edward Cullen in the Twilight
franchise he entered the realm of sudden
super stardom he also developed a
reputation for having poor hygiene a
source on the set of New Moon told E
news he stinks I mean it's awful he
never showers and it drives people on
the set crazy he completely reeks
not everyone Associates Hibbett Twilight
complained about Pattinson's mouth
Kristen Stewart told people he smells
great it's kind of an animalist thing
that goes on it went along with the
movie so it was perfect when extra ass
patterns turned about not washing his
hair for six weeks Pattinson made a
shocking admission saying if you don't
care if your hair is clean or not then
why would you watch it not to worry
becoming a model for Dior helped pattern
soon clean up his act in 2014 he told
the Wall Street Journal I can't tell if
it's because of my association with Dior
or because I'm older but I've started
moisturizing it's been a quite profound
change in my life his co-stars must
appreciate him arriving on set fresh and
clean
Brad Pitt has long been a sex symbol
he's been crowned People's sexiest man
alive twice but the star is also famous
for having poor hygiene
fit readily amidst the not showering
regularly but insists baby wipes keep
him fresh his Inglorious Bastards
co-star Eli Roth told people after a
scene it brought out to get next to me
for a close-up shot and he said damn
you're right I said I didn't have time
to shower he said baby wipes man baby
wipes Fitz also stopped using soap and
antiperspirin because of concerns for
the environment and the toxins the
products contain opting for a homemade
concoction not everyone was as impressed
as Roth wolves with Pitts hygiene hack
even if it's children of staged and
Mutiny over his insufficient bathing
habits if his family is complaining can
you imagine what his co-stars have to
say isn't alone in his aversion to
soap bathing and deodorant many stars
have come out in recent years as being
infrequent bathers Mila Kunis and Ashton
Kutcher talked about their relaxed
approach to bathing with Dax Shepard on
the armchair expert podcast and Jake
Gyllenhaal told Vanity Fair more and
more I find a bathing to be less
necessary
Shia LaBeouf doesn't claim to be a
method actor but while filming the War
epic Fury the cast and crew were
troubled by the extreme methods he used
to get into character the buff told
today's digital that after landing the
role he trained with the 41st infantry
of the U.S national guard he admitted I
pulled my tooth out a knife to my face
up and spent days watching horses die I
didn't bathe for four months it seems
wild because it's a scar but you get a
lot of scars doing these things more so
emotionally than than the physical stuff
that's really the smallest part of the
job A source told the Daily Mail Shire
was warned about his behavior by several
people on set including Brad Pitt and
director David Ayer you read that right
even Pitt was offended by LaBeouf's poor
hygiene and self-mutilation according to
the Daily Mail he even wound up staying
in a different lodging than the rest of
the cast and crew because of his poor
hygiene and troubling Behavior Jim
Carrey's bizarre and annoying Antics on
the set of man on the moon was so
strange Universal didn't want any behind
the scenes footage released in Christmas
Netflix documentary Jim and Andy the
great beyond audiences soreness footage
for the first time it's really weird
it's totally surreal while making Milos
Foreman's biopic about The Eccentric
comedian Andy Kaufman Kerry got lost in
the roar staying in character on set for
four months of filming in the
documentary Kerry says that when he got
the role Kaufman Spirit tapped him on
the shoulder and took over what happened
afterwards was out of my control Kerry
certainly seems possessed by something
and it wasn't always fun for the casting
crew for example Carrie made everyone on
set call him Andy or Tony when Kerry
inhabited Kaufman's belligerent Alter
Ego Tony Clifton he was combative and
rude especially with Jerry Lawler the
professional wrestler who plays himself
in the film going so far as to spit in
his face Ultima League Kerry won a
Golden Globe for his performance but for
the casting crew Kerry's method acting
was unprofessional and disruptive to the
production
in 2005 when Matthew McConaughey was
named People's sexiest man alive he told
the world I haven't worn deodorant in 20
years McConaughey's stance isn't driven
by health concerns the actor just
doesn't think it's necessary in a 2008
interview with Playboy McConaughey said
the women in my life including my mother
have all said hey your natural smell
smells One Like a Man and two smells
like you that is until he worked with
Kate Hudson who begged him to use her
natural deodorant while filming Fool's
Gold McConaughey explained to Playboy
she always brings a salt rock which is
some natural deodorant and says would
you please put this on apparently others
have worked with McConaughey and found
absolutely nothing offensive about his
smell Yvette Nicole Brown who worked
with the actor on Tropic Thunder told
the Jess Kegel show he actually smelled
good he smells like granola and good
living it must have been extra hot in
Australia while filming Fool's gone or
maybe McConaughey started taking
multiple showers every day either way he
and Hudson have made a couple of films
together and they had great screen
chemistry EV even if she thought he
smelled bad
Shailene Woodley is known for being
health conscious and into natural
healing and natural beauty products well
one of her co-stars didn't appreciate
her herbalism Miles Teller said he hated
kissing her while filming The
Spectacular Now because her numerous
herbal tinctures tasted bad Tyler told
vulture she would take these herbal
supplements these Chinese herbal
supplements and they tasted like crap
and she would always eat them right
before he had a kissing scene Woodley
didn't enjoy shooting their kissing
scenes either reportedly she took issue
with teller's breath too Woodley told
vulture would have to kiss in a scene
and he'd be like Shay you just ate dirt
and I'd be like miles you just ate
licorice it was just as ongoing back and
forth
think no
no surprise fans who have seen Woodley
and tell her in four films together but
don't worry this popular film Duo are
friends despite their complaints about
each other's onset habits Woodley also
apparently loves teller's recent work in
Top Gun Maverick telling people that
teller is a quote wildly talented actor
although teller appreciated the praise
he told the publication she certainly
didn't have to do anything publicly for
me to know that she supports me and that
we are really good friends we've been
very close for a long time maybe next
time it meets up to play romantic leads
they can just agree on breath Mentor
universally an offensive glass of water
before kissing scenes what is Jennifer
Lawrence quotes tortured her Hunger
Games Leading Men by eating stinky food
before her kissing scenes with both Liam
Hemsworth and Josh Hutcherson and she
didn't feel bad about it one bit
Lawrence confirmed this on The Graham
Norton Show whenever he had to kiss Josh
and Liam for The Hunger Games who cares
yeah I need like mustard and tuna like
who cares Hemsworth had a chance to
complain about Lawrence's gross onset
food choices to Jimmy Fallon anytime I
had to kiss Jennifer was pretty
uncomfortable really awkward when Fallon
was baffled by this declaration
Hemsworth explained she's one of my best
friends I love her but if we had a
kissing scene she would make a point of
eating Garlic or tuna fish not to worry
these two are clearly friends who enjoy
giving each other a hard time from
stories that surfaced about the
practical jokes and pranks Paul during
the production of The Hunger Games
movies it seems like Lawrence's food
choices were more of a joke than poor
hygiene or a deliberate tactic to
Tormentor leading man and the men
occasionally fought back purchased
someone scared Lauren so badly that she
peed her pants when he puts a music to
dummy in the bathroom with a trailer if
you're gonna dish it out you better
learn to take it right
Jason Siegel was a smoker when he landed
a starring role in the hit series How I
Met Your Mother reportedly his co-star
and on-screen wife Alison Hannigan told
him she wouldn't do any kissing scenes
with him because of his Smoker's breath
Hannigan told Digital Spy I cannot stand
cigarette smoke it's like getting an
ashtray and he's trying to be polite by
having gum or mince but it doesn't help
according to Hannigan the pair developed
a system she explained mummy started the
pilots he was like get me to stop
smoking or be your best friend so we did
this bet where he would owe me ten
dollars every time he had a cigarette
after the first day he owed me 200
fortunately Siegel quit but it only
lasted a year after which stress got him
started again but despite being grossed
out by his smoking Hannigan loved
working with seagull on the series she
broke down crying or trying to explain
why she would miss him during a Casper
Union on the talk and the feelings were
obviously Mutual I he taught me a lot of
how to be a man I gotta say I was 25
when I took the show and I think we've
all been through a lot uh personally it
goes to show that just because an actor
was a gross onset habit it doesn't mean
that co-stars won't grow to love them
allegedly Arnold Schwarzenegger
intentionally farted in the face of one
of his co-stars Maria Margulies is
probably best known for playing
Professor Sprouts in Harry Potter and
Juliet's nurse in baz luhrmann's iconic
film Romeo and Juliet her hilarious and
brutally honest answers to interview
questions have made her a popular and
entertaining talk show guest the British
actor told I've got news for you that
she didn't enjoy meeting Schwarzenegger
while filming the horror movie end of
days and she hasn't gotten over it
saying he's a bit too full of himself I
don't care for him at all he's a
republican which I don't like he was
actually quite rude he farted in my face
now I fart of course I do but I don't
fart in people's faces he did it
deliberately right in my face Not only
was this onset Behavior gross but
magalies also found it offensive saying
I was playing Satan's sister and he was
killing me so he had me in a position
where I couldn't escape and lying on the
floor and he just farted despite variety
reaching out to Schwarzenegger's
representatives for comment it appears
the actor has never addressed her
accusation
Johnny Galecki is an hygienic habit of
disposing of his gum on the set of The
Big Bang Theory was so gross one of his
co-stars couldn't resist talking about
it if you are familiar with the comedy
series you know the elevator in the
apartment building by Sheldon Leonard
and Penny lived remained out of order
for years on end Kunal Naya who played
Raj Koothrappali on the series revealed
to Daily Express that the onset stairs
led to nowhere saying there's a wall
there where Johnny Galecki for 12 years
would stick his chewing him on I'm not
joking there's a wall of 3 000 dried
chewing gum from Johnny Galecki this is
the totally gross onset habit but you
know what's even more disgusting some
fans would probably spend a pretty penny
to buy that wall of chewing gum that's a
weird piece of celebrity memorabilia
foreign